next hillary clinton discusses the most
important issue in america
sexism uh yeah it's all because of
sexism alrighty folks today we're going
to go through one of the great master
classes or should i say mistress classes
what of all time hillary clinton gave a
master class it's supposed to be life
advice and life lessons it mostly turns
into a gripe session and also a story of
achievement and accomplishment about
hillary clinton by hillary clinton
because if there's one person on earth
who loves hillary clinton it is indeed
hillary clinton this video is brought to
you by naturally it's clean
everybody will be knocked down the
question is will you get back up
i made so many gaffes and mistakes
i want to share my life lessons with the
hope that it might help you as you
navigate your own life
what difference at this point does it
make
yeah that's not the real trailer guys so
we're gonna go through some of the
highlights and lowlights of hillary
clinton's master class in failure here
we get hillary clinton's batman origin
story
i never thought i would be a
an elected politician but i cared deeply
and passionately about trying to
help people and make our
country fairer and juster and better and
it helps to keep me centered and focused
in the face of
all the outside noise
okay so that is a person who want to be
president of the united states since she
was in the womb she was eminently
political going all the way back to the
beginning of her life and then of course
she married bill how would you describe
your relationship we're kidding
ourselves i mean she wrote his coattails
he went to the white house and then she
was elected senator of new york having
never held elected office her entire
life based on the fact that she was the
person who was technically married to
bill clinton so yeah she's she's an
inspiration to us all
mary and joseph next we hear hillary
clinton talk about her own perception of
herself after meeting robert byrd the
senator who used to be a member of the
kkk you know when i was elected to the
senate in november of 2000. i went to
see senator robert byrd who'd been there
a very long time everybody said he's the
dean of the senate you should go see him
and he looked at me and he goes are you
a workhorse or a show horse i said oh
senator i am a workhorse he goes that's
good cause that's what we need
and so i began to refer to myself as a
workhorse not a show horse she was a
workhorse who had worked her way to the
top through the sheer hard work of
marrying the presidents of the united
states yeah man workhorse not show horse
[Laughter]
[Applause]
alrighty next we get to hear from
hillary clinton about her physical
stamina she doesn't have the stamina
actually what she has to say here is uh
kind of funny believe it or not you know
having the stamina the physical
endurance to
keep going uh in hard times i probably
should have taken a day or two off when
they
said guess what you've got pneumonia and
hear the antibiotics and my doctor did
say why don't you take a few days off
and i said oh no i'll be fine i've got
such great stamina well i do
but even my stamina was uh not a match
for
getting woozy at a public event and then
you know having people say i was dying
so
you got to have stamina but you also
have to have common sense that is the
most introspective thing i've ever heard
from hillary clinton even there she's
like and i do have great stamina my
stamina is unbelievable it's impressive
it's just the greatest stamina in the
world i said she doesn't have the
stamina if she actually had a little
more introspection she'd be a lot more
likable as a candidate and probably as a
human being but she verges on it right
there yeah maybe i should have taken a
couple days off instead of collapsing
into a van
alrighty next we get hillary clinton
talking about her warm wonderful
relationship with barack obama who
pretty obviously cannot stand her when
he spoke
at the funeral for those murdered at
mother emanuel church in charleston
south carolina and then began to sing
amazing grace
i thought it was just
one of the most powerful
poignant touching
moments i've ever seen well it
definitely was more amazing and touching
and pointing than when she actually
attempted to affect a black accent while
speaking down south i don't feel no ways
tired it is amazing how hillary clinton
shifted from being the person who was
really pissed that obama destroyed her
in 2008 to now being his biggest backer
when she presumably might need his
support for some time in the future
people are going to see this and say
okay she's pandering to black people is
it working
we will continue going through hillary
clinton's incredible master class in
just one second first this year the
daily wire has a brand new partner
naturally it's clean when you bring a
product into your home you want to make
sure your hard earned money is going to
a brand that believes in the same
principles you do here at the daily wire
we're working overtime to fight for your
values we love to take on new sponsors
that support that mission as well
naturally it's clean is a home cleaning
company dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals their secret powerful
plant-based enzymes nature solution to
cleaning when i say powerful i'm talking
about hospital-grade enzyme cleaning
power they've got solutions for pretty
much every need in your house from the
kitchen to the bathroom to the laundry
room naturally it's clean has a
specialized formula to clean the area
effectively their products truly speak
for themselves they have the science to
back it up to make things even better
all their products are manufactured in
the united states they can ship it
directly to your door for free we've
been using naturally it's clean at my
house let me tell you it makes
everything very very clean and very very
safe at the same time i'm encouraging my
listeners to start with four of their
top products conveniently packaged
together in their daily wire essentials
kit and for a limited time my listeners
can receive 15 off their order just
enter promo code ben at checkout when
you visit naturallyitsclean.com
ben try these incredible products in
your home today shipping is free
everything is made right here in the
united states again try our naturally
it's clean daily wire four pack today by
going to naturallyitsclean.com
use promo code ben to receive 15 off
your purchase don't delay make the
smarter safer choice for your home
cleaning needs today but naturally it's
clean
and next we get to hillary clinton's
brush with actual danger no not the time
that she was shot at on a tarmac that
never happened the time that donald
trump was trying to stalk her in front
of a hundred million americans on
national television you know when i was
in um the second debate with donald
trump he was stalking me around the
stage you know he has this
bullying
macho
over
weaning personality and he wants to
dominate everybody in his path at all
times and i was trying to answer the
questions the questions from the
moderators
but at the same time my mind is going
what am i supposed to do with this
he's clearly
demonstrating particularly to his voters
that you know he's the man up there and
i'm the little woman and look at him
dominating me that's happened in a
variety of debates that's actually not
what happened in this debate donald
trump was not following her around the
stage it's something al gore did in 2000
with george w bush and bush's response
was super funny but can you get things
done
and i believe i can and hillary clinton
has played this game before so in 2000
she was running against daniel rick
lazio and there was a point at which
lazio went over to her podium and
presented her with a piece of paper and
this was treated by the media as though
he had walked over and physically
assaulted her so this this kind of woe
is me i'm a victim donald trump is going
to physically intimidate me it's really
annoying and irritating and the fact
that she's still harping on this is
really silly next hillary clinton
discusses the most important issue in
america especially with regard to
hillary clinton
sexism i think sexism really is rooted
in ideal images of what girls and women
are supposed to be
so if you hear someone or if you are
hearing yourself saying well i i wish
you know
she were taller i wish she were thinner
i wish she were
prettier
that's all part of a sexist judging
system
that has impact on how girls
see themselves their confidence how they
approach the world
yeah it's all because of sexism you know
sexism they got you elected to the
senate based on zero qualifications and
then selected to secretary of state
based on pretty much zero qualifications
and then running for president of the
united states based on all of those past
elevations based largely on your claim
to be the potential first woman
president but it was all sexism all
brutal vicious sexism by the way the
examples that she uses of of sexism like
she should be taller she should be
better looking all of those things apply
to every male candidate as well it turns
out that when it comes to the art of
politics people always want better
looking taller people the sort of
nonsense that hillary clinton lost the
presidency because she is a woman
literally the only reason that hillary
clinton was even a position to win the
presidency is because she was a woman
all right one element of this master
class is that hillary clinton actually
read out the speech that she would have
given had she won the 2016 election
fortunately we never got to hear that in
real life until now now you have to pay
to hear it i think about my mother every
day i dream of going up to her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states i
hesitate to make too much fun here
because i think her mom passed away
recently but yeah hillary clinton
weeping over not getting to be president
the first rule of politics never give
the job to the person who wants it the
most and hillary clinton is an excellent
example of why you should never give the
power to the person who desperately
wants the power
[Laughter]
already i know about you but when i
watched that master class mistress class
non-binary gender class from hillary
clinton i learned so much i learned
about how she's a victim and also about
how she's a hero but a victim and also a
victim but also a hero because america
is mean to her because she's a victim
who's a hero i hope that you learned as
much as i did
i'm just chilling in cedar rapids
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang